so now I'd like to introduce today's
speaker Michael McGee
Michael McGee is a professor of
materials
at Stanford University and the
co-director of our energy innovation and
emerging technology certificate which is
offered through the Stanford center for
professional development
his primary research interests are
developing new materials for smart
windows and solar cells
he sought courses on nanotechnology
organic semiconductors solar cells and
polymer science
he received his undergraduate degree in
physics from Princeton University and
his PhD was in material science from the
University of California at Santa
Barbara there he did research from
polymer lasers in the lab of Nobel
laureate Alan Higa Michael has strong
industry connections acting as a
technical adviser to next energy plant
PV and synovium and from his teaching
and mentorship there's an impressive
crowd of alumni from his lab many are
now working in Silicon Valley startups
nine of which have founded their own
companies and for receiving the Forbes
30 under 30 award I'd now like to turn
the floor over to Michael hello everyone
thank you for participating in this
webinar I'm gonna bring you up to speed
on some exciting developments with
perovskite semiconductors and their use
in solar cells but to get started let me
just say a couple things about the solar
industry in general in this graph here
if you look at the orange curve you can
see that about during the oil crisis in
the 70s solar panels cost about $100 per
watt of power that they could generate
in peak sunlight and then that dropped
rapidly and then stagnated during the
90s when there wasn't a whole lot of
interest in solar energy and then in the
last five or six years the price has
dived down again and now it's at about
50 or 60 cents per watt and with that
price reduction if you look at the blue
curve you can see the installations
rapidly rising with time and now about
65,000 megawatts are being installed
per year and that that's about the
equivalent of 65 coal-fired power plants
so this is this is very very exciting
and even more broadly I would say that
in last year or two we've reached a
tipping point on addressing climate
change and a lot of people are getting
on board ranging from you know
politicians to the utility companies and
and I think there's a commitment now and
that renewable energy is likely to do
very well so solar still needs to get a
little bit better if the overall cost of
an installed system was about one dollar
per watt then solar electricity would be
about the same cost as electricity from
a gas fired power plant and and here I'm
only shown you the price for the panel
now installing the panel is even more
expensive and a utility still that could
be maybe a dollar fifty per watt and if
you did it on a house it might be
something like three and a half dollars
per watt now today I'm going to be
focusing more on the solar cells
themselves but that's what I do and and
when you look at that data you realize
that with those expensive installation
costs what people who make panels need
to do is raise the efficiency because
then you can get the power you need with
a lower number of panels and you can
calculate how valuable it is to make a
panel more efficient and if you run
those numbers you find that you should
be willing to pay an extra three cents
per watt for an efficiency point so in
other words if you could get a 20%
efficient panel instead of 19 you should
be willing to pay 53 cents per watt for
it instead of $0.50 per watt and indeed
if you let you look at the market
there is a range of products where the
efficiency goes from $0.15 per I'm sorry
from 15% efficiency up to about 21 and
indeed those are the variations in the
price in some cases people are willing
to pay even more for example in
neighborhood where I live in Menlo Park
California a lot of people have to pay
up to 40 cent per watt I'm sorry 40 cent
per kilowatt hour for their electricity
because we have a tiered system and the
more power you use the the higher rate
you have to pay and a lot of people are
switching to electric vehicles and
that's raising their electricity needs
and so they might want to install six or
seven kilowatts of panels on their roof
but they also don't have very large
rooms and a lot of their roof is not
useful because they have chimneys and
vents and some of the roof might be
shaded and some of the roofs have
complex shapes and so they simply can't
get the capacity that they would like
when the panel's only have fifteen or
sixteen percent efficiency and so it can
make sense for them to really pay a
premium to get higher efficiency panels
and and so I think there's a strong
drive for that and here on the next
slide we we can see how the efficiency
has evolved over time for some of the
most important technologies let's start
with that black curve because that's
silicon and right now about 90 maybe 92
percent of the market is crystalline
silicon solar cells and the world-record
efficiency is 25 percent but that's for
a small cell and that's for expensive
things we're done to make it the panels
would be more at maybe 15 to 21 percent
but the other thing I want you to see
from that curve is there has hardly been
any progress in raising
that efficiency since the late 90s oh
that efficiency is pretty much stagnant
above it that's the green curve that's
gallium arsenide and you can go up to
28% with that but it's a very expensive
technology right now it's about 40 times
more expensive than silicon and I don't
I don't see a pathway for adjourn at
across a cost reduction there if you
look at the pink and blue those are
so-called thin-film technologies copper
indium gallium selenide and cadmium
telluride and the idea there is to use a
smaller amount of semiconductor to try
to reduce cost and you can see the
efficiency evolved over time and now
both of them are at 22 percent but the
news of today is is that red curve the
parofsky it just came out of nowhere
around 2012 and the efficiency has
soared up to 22 catching up with cigs
and cadmium telluride and never in
history have as a semiconductor advanced
so quickly for solar cell applications
and I think there two reasons for that
one there are some very beneficial
properties that I'm getting ready to
tell you about and the other is that
there's a community of solar cell
researchers who've learned a lot over
the years and these people really know
how to take a new material and make a
good solar stall with it so things move
faster now maybe there's some of you out
there who don't have an engineering
background so let me just say a little
bit about semiconductors these are
materials that have a bunch of
continuous energy levels that are filled
with electrons that make up what we call
the valence band and then on the energy
diagram there are a lot of energies
where there are no states that electrons
can go into and then there's a mostly
empty band called the conduction dam
and in between that is something called
the energy band gap and I will refer to
that number a lot in this webinar when
light comes in we can excite an electron
from the valence band up to the
conduction band and it'll fall to the
bottom of that band if we excite it up
high into the band and in full that
electron falls back down in a process we
call recombination that energy is stored
and what we want to do is get the
electron to go to one side of the
semiconductor and get the hole or the
positive charge to go to the other side
and we want to extract that power as
electricity that's basically how a solar
cell works and the bandgap is really
important because if we have a large
band gap then most of the photons and
the solar spectrum don't have enough
energy to get the electron up into the
conduction band and so we can't absorb
those photons on the other hand if we
take a small band gap then the photons
excite the carrier's high up into the
band and then they fall to the bottom of
the band in a process we call
thermalization and we lose all that
energy and so with a low bandgap we get
a low voltage with a high band gap we
get a high voltage but we get a low
current because we get one charged
carrier per photon absorbed and so on
the curve of efficiency versus bandgap
you see that it starts slow rises to a
peak and then it falls and and from this
we see that the ideal bandgap is about
1.4 electron volts and with one
semiconductor the highest efficiency you
can get with the Sun is about 31% now
there is a chick there's several chicks
for beating that limit but I'm
focus on what I think is the most
important one we can make tandems or
other people call the multi-junction
solar cells and the idea is to put a
large band gap solar cell on top of a
small band gap solar cell when you do
that the high-energy photons are
absorbed in large band gap cell and
because it has a large band gap we can
generate a higher voltage so we can
capture more of the energy from those
photons and then the lower energy
photons they will go through and we'll
use a second cell with a smaller band
gap to harvest those two so we can do
better that way and and theoretically we
can do up to 42% but practically for one
Junction silicon is limited to about 25
and I think practically 35% might be
about the best we can do with
cost-effective means but 35 is you know
considerably more efficient than 25 and
so I think it's a shock t'v goal this
plot here just shows the efficiency you
can get as a function of the band gaps
on the y-axis that's the band gap of the
low bandgap cell the x-axis is the high
you can see there but 42 is possible and
it tells us that for this application
the band gaps we want are about 1.1
electron volts and 1.8 so some numbers
to keep in mind as I go forward for
single Junction we want one point for
evey and for two junctions we want one
point one and one point eight okay now
let me tell you about the perab skates
themselves perovskites are essentially a
salt and you can dissolve them in a
polar solvent and when you do you really
don't have parofsky in your vial of
solution you have ions in there and but
then when you cast it or print it and
form a thin film this
solvent will evaporate away and as it
does this salt will reform and it'll be
solid and you'll get a crystal structure
like you can see on the right side of
the slide the word perovskite would what
it really means is just that crystal
structure it means the atoms are
arranged in in that way but a specific
example of perovskites that makes a good
solar cell is methylammonium lead iodide
but there are other options and on the
next slide you'll see on the top as we
go from the left to the right we're
gradually reducing the amount of iodine
and adding and bromine and you can see
that the color is changing and that's
because the band gap is increasing from
1.6 electron volts to 2 point 3 electron
volts the visible spectrum is from about
2 Evie up to 3 Evie so when the band gap
is 1.6 the semiconductor can absorb all
of the visible photons and that makes
the film look black but as we go to the
right we get to where the film cannot
absorb the red and then it can absorb
the yellow and and that's why the film
starts to be colored if you look at the
bottom we've replaced the methyl
ammonium with another organic cation
called forma Medini amande you see that
that's and dropped the bandgap from 1.6
down to 1.48
and later in the talk I'll show you that
we can replace lead with tin and so by
changing all the elements in the formula
a B X 3 we have a variety of knobs for
adjusting the bandgap for whatever
application and by the way if you use
chlorine you can raise the bandgap all
the way up to 3 evey and you can also
make red green and blue LEDs but that
would be a topic for another day
on this slide you can see the cross
section of a typical Purab skate solar
cell on the left with the original
composition that a few labs like Nam
View Park Tommy Osaka and Henry Smith
and Michael gratzel discovered and it
evolved from the die since its high
solar cell it has a film of titania
nanoparticles filled in with the perab
skate and then sandwiched between a gold
electrode and a transparent fluorine
doped tin oxide electrode but pretty
quickly Henry snakes realized that you
don't actually need the titania
nanoparticles and you can use the planar
structure on the right where it's it's
just an uninterrupted film of perovskite
on the bottom is an energy diagram and
one of the key design rules is shown
there on the left is titania and that's
an example of what we call an electron
transport material and it needs to have
its conduction band which is that top
energy level being lower than the
conduction band of the profs kite that
way electrons can go over there but
holes which go upward on an energy
diagram they can't go in and that way
electrons can only escape to the left
in contrast on the right side we have a
material just generically called the
hole transport material it can accept
holes but it cannot accept electrons so
these materials sometimes we call them
selective or carrier selective contacts
and and they provide the mechanism to
have electrons go out on one side and
holes on the other parofsky have many
wonderful properties we've seen they
have a tunable bandgap they're very
highly absorbing they absorb as well as
any semiconductor out there they if you
illuminate them with pulses of light you
can see that the charge carriers live
for a long time
that means there's very slow
recombination which is one of the most
desirable properties for a solar cell
a lot of semiconductors have defects at
their surfaces and charge carriers will
recombine there but that is very slow in
the prostate for a lot of semiconductors
if you have a thin film with lots of
small crystals there will be
recombination at the boundaries between
crystals but that seems to be very slow
with perovskites
and it's all of those properties that
make it possible to get as high as 22
percent efficiency and moreover we can
print these things even on plastic and
so we can we can make a flexible solar
cell at at low temperature and that's
the property that the cadmium telluride
and cigs don't have so that's the good
news a balanced webinar has to present
some of the bad news as well these
materials are very sensitive to water a
lot of you probably know that salts take
up water and and these perovskites are
no exception but that just really means
that the panels need to be packaged well
and it means that you need to cover the
perovskite with an electrode promptly in
the factory you wouldn't want to have
profs kite films sitting around
especially if the factory were in a
humid environment so you need to you
need to get it packaged promptly another
one it turns out the halogens that's the
iodine or the bromine they move around
very easily and they can react with
metal especially silver but I'll show
you in a slide or two how to avoid that
problem and finally methyl ammonium can
leave the film relatively easy it'll
slowly come out at 80 degrees and by the
time you're at a hundred hundred ten
degrees it will come out very quickly
and that could be a problem for field
use where the temperature you might hit
80 degrees C
but it's also a problem in manufacturing
where sometimes you you might have a
processing step let's say 130 degrees my
group has has figured out how to
mitigate some of these problems we
wanted to put a transparent indium tin
oxide electrode on top that's the
material that's used in your your flat
panel display and your your laptop and
we wanted to sputter it but it turned
out that process would damage the
parofsky
so we needed to put down on a buffer
layer and for that we used aluminum
doped zinc oxide nanoparticles we could
deposit those from solution in a way
that did not damage the porosity and
then we could sputter on that these are
inorganic nanoparticles they're a little
more robust and they would protect the
perab scape and when we did that we
would put these solar cells on a hot
plate in air at a hundred degrees and if
you look at the picture here you'll see
the the square in the center that's
where the eye tio is and they're the
perovskite maintained its color but
outside of that where there was no
indium tin oxide we found the material
very quickly converted to lead iodide as
the methyl ammonium left the film so
this demonstrated that the eye tio would
hold the methyl ammonium in and moreover
we found that iodine doesn't seem to
react with the indium tin oxide and so
we could run this solar cell in air with
no packaging for a week on a hot plate
at a hundred degrees under one Sun
illumination so this is a very big
breakthrough switching away from metals
to using the indium tin oxide electrode
but that's only one of the things you
can do before I give the next let me
just also point out some other research
groups have found you can also use
carbon paste as an electrode
again showing that the key to stability
seems to be getting away from metal the
and the second paper explains in detail
why gold is problematic it actually
diffuses into the perab skate so the
second thing we do to keep
methylammonium from escaping is just
simply not use methylammonium and if you
use mixtures of cesium and for momentum
you get a compound that we find to be
stable at 150 degrees Celsius cesium is
a little bit too small to properly fit
into the perovskite lattice form am
edenia ms a little bit too large but
mixtures of the two seem to make a very
robust parofsky crystal structure and
then the third really important strategy
is simply to properly package the solar
cells and we talked a lot to the team at
DuPont here in Silicon Valley who makes
a lot of these packaging materials and
then we went to a company called d2
solar that packages solar cells and
makes panels for other solar cell
startups that don't have all of that
equipment and here you you put a rubber
edge feel that you can see in black
around the edge and then in the interior
you have encapsulation made of things
like ethylene vinyl acetate or anion
armor called sherlyn and then you pull
vacuum to get any air out and you you
you heat it to about 130 degrees and
press on it and forms a really nice
package and this is just industry
standard packaging for solar cells and
then when you do this you can you can
put it through a torture test that the
solar industry uses to predict if
something is going to last outside for
25 years they they test for a thousand
hours at 85 degrees Celsius and 85%
humidity which is a really aggressive
test and we did that and one of our
three packages failed at least and water
got in but two of them didn't and we
passed this test after a thousand hours
actually the efficiency increased and so
this is extremely encouraging that we
passed that test so the outlook on on
stability is that if you use the more
stable perovskites you use impermeable
and unreactive electrodes and proper
packaging it looks like at least thermal
stability can be obtained we've also
done a temperature cycling torture test
where we go back and forth from 80
degrees C into a freezer at minus 40 to
see if the shrinking and expansion will
cause it to pop apart and we passed that
on the first time and we're working on
long-term tests under light but those
take a bit longer and at least after a
thousand hours things look encouraging
but it'll be a while before will have
longer term tests so a year ago I was a
bit scared over the prospects of making
these devices stable because they were
only lasting four minutes but huge
progress has been made and I think the
outlook is positive now on stability now
let me turn back to the tandem solar
cell so we know this concept works the
world record is 46 percent and that's
made with single crystals three five
semiconductors basically the gallium
arsenide family I think that world
record has four different band gaps in
it unfortunately those cells are
absolutely tiny because they cost over
forty thousand dollars per meter squared
to make but so I believe the future is
is a much much cheaper tandem and on the
bottom I think we could just use
vention all semiconductors like psyllium
silicon or copper indium gallium
selenide which both have the perfect
one-point-one UV bandgap and then on the
top we need something that works even
when it's not a single crystal something
that you would say is defect tolerant
and the parofsky has really emerged of
an exciting candidate for that there are
a couple ways that people could imagine
making these tandems they're actually
probably far more than two but here in
my view the two most promising you could
make a complete pur off skite cell that
has its own electrodes and mechanically
stack it on top of let's just say a
silicon cell that has its own electrodes
an advantage of that is that you can
just use any silicon cell you could you
could get them from different companies
and they wouldn't have to modify their
product at all and you just you know
package the perovskite cells on top on
the other hand you can make a monolithic
cell where the perovskite is directly
deposited on to the silicon or cigs
solar cell if you do that you you have
to match the current densities if one of
them puts out less current than the
other it will set the current for the
the stack and and that means you have to
calculate and obtain exactly the right
band gaps so that the two cells each get
the right amount of current and there's
some engineering that has to be done to
to make the right interfaces between the
two with the mechanically stacked tandem
you don't have to perfectly current
match on the next slide I'll show you
can still wire them up in series with
each other you can have a string of
silicon in series with a string of
perovskite cells and you can just simply
adjust the areas in order to get current
matching and if you do that your panel
will still
have two wires coming out of it a few
years ago my group set out to
demonstrate that all of this was
possible and the the easier one to make
is mechanically stock tandem and and and
that's what we did and back then our
perovskite only had twelve point three
percent efficiency and we put it on top
of seventeen percent efficient silicon
and we also had seventeen percent
efficient cigs
and when you put those under the
perovskite the efficiency of course
drops because a lot of the photons are
absorbed in the top cell but you could
still get five point seven and if you
add those up you get eighteen which is
better than either cell by itself since
then there have been a lot of advances
and I'll just have to skip straight to
the world record and this is from
Christophe beliefs lab in Switzerland
and with a lot of things optimized the
efficiency is already at twenty five
percent and I see a clear path to get
this up to thirty percent efficiency
my group was also the first to
demonstrate a two terminal tandem in
partnership with Tonio UN ICC at MIT
they made a silicon cell with a tunnel
Junction on top and then we put up her
off sky cell on top of it and here we
got 13.7% and we identified we were
having a big problem with our whole
transport layer absorbing photons which
we didn't want it to do but a lot of
progress has been made on that as well
now there the the worldwide community
has has made many compositions of pur
off states and we have a lot to choose
from we don't have a great one point
easy bandgap material but we do have
some pretty good ones with one point six
electron volts and in this next slide
you'll see with 17% cesium 83% formid
inium and 17% bro
83% iodine we've been able to make a
two-terminal tandem with 23.6%
efficiency
that was a validated world record by
NREL about ten days ago and this is also
this is the same composition that past
those damp heat test that I talked about
earlier so when we selected this
composition it was not only for
efficiency but we were also selecting it
to to be very stable finally I want to
tell you about something that's not
published yet in a peer-reviewed journal
in collaboration with Henry Smith group
from Oxford we've figured out how to
make a low bandgap Purab skite and make
all perovskite tandems this is on the
archives journal right now as the paper
is going through peer review and here
we're adjusting the ratio of lead to tin
in the compound and if the tin
composition is around 50% we can get the
bandgap down to 1.2 electron volts and
that's not perfect for a two terminal
tandem but it's getting very close to
being the perfect bandgap and here you
see the cross-sectional SCM of a two
terminal tandem and right now we're at
about 17 percent efficiency and we
understand what some of the problems are
our 1.2 ez material is far too thin we
just haven't figured out how to deposit
a thick high-quality film yet but I
think that will certainly be figured out
and we needed a 1.8 evey bandgap to have
proper current matching but we also need
a better composition for that band gap
and and I see no fundamental reason why
that can't be done so I expect this
efficiency to rise very
we also made a four terminal tandem with
the low bandgap material and right now
we're at about twenty percent efficiency
and this very new material we haven't
been able to do full stability testing
but it was completely stable over 20
hours of testing under one Sun so I
think the outlook for efficiency and
stability is wonderful you know you've
seen how the single junction efficiency
rapidly rose to 22 I'd be very surprised
if it's saturated there I'm optimistic
that single Junction cells might go to
25 and and that the tandems will go up
over 30% efficiency I know someone's
going to ask me about the implications
of lead being toxic so let me address
that before we turn it over to the QA
there's this paper in Nature Materials
that's written by toxicologists who have
no reason to be biased towards you know
perovskite solar cells and they talk
about you know what happens when people
are exposed to lead and you know one
thing is very clear the factories would
have to be run in a proper way to
protect the workers and make sure that
they're not exposed to lead and you know
there are plenty of industries that that
use lead and other toxic compounds and
and and it is possible to protect
workers and then when the panels expire
and are decommissioned it will be very
important to you know take the panel
apart and and properly capture the lead
and then something else to think about
these panels are only going to have
about one gram of lead in the perovskite
layer and just to put that into
perspective people may not realize this
but today panels already have 16 grams
of lead that is in the lead solder so
it's a very small amount of lead and
moreover if you took the panel and
bashed on it for five
minutes with a sledgehammer and threw it
into a lake well then yes the lead would
escape but short of doing things like
that it would be very hard for the lead
to actually get out of a properly
packaged module there are five companies
that I know of in the startup stage
Oxford PV is certainly the largest and
they're developing a two-terminal tandem
with perovskites on silicon a full
disclosure I have co-founded iris PV
with Colin Bailey and we're taking a
different approach we are mechanically
stacking Purab skates on silicon hunt
energy led by Michael Irwin in Dallas
they're going with single Junction Purab
skates so they're going for a ultra low
cost product and Soleil and and Poland
seems to be doing flexible trough sky
cells and I don't know a lot about way
who and China but I have seen pictures
of panels that are almost two feet
across
they've already been able to print if
you want to learn more we have a
certificate program on energy
innovations and emerging technologies I
teach a three-hour module on solar cells
in that module I say a whole lot more
about the industry in general and I go
through all of the important solar cell
technologies they're not just
perovskites
and more broadly and the certificate I
think we cover all of the important
topics on energy so you can learn a
whole lot there these are all the people
that not not all but some of the people
who helped to do the research that I
talked about from Stanford and and some
of our partners from outside Stanford
and certainly none of this would have
been possible without them with that I
thank you all for attending and I will
do my best to answer your questions
great thank you for that excellent
presentation and for sharing some of the
very latest research in collaborations
so now I'd like to hand it back over to
Mike so he can answer some of the
questions that you've been sending
through okay they've typed a lot of the
questions for me I can see them on the
screen and lots of good ones here I'll
start with our Piroska it's flexible or
rigid the film's we're using are about
1/2 micron thick and actually pretty
much everything is flexible when it is
that thin so what determines whether or
not the solar cell is flexible is simply
what substrate it is deposited on and
because our processing is at low
temperature we can build the solar cell
on plastic which is flexible and there
are indeed demonstrations in the
literature of flexible solar cells I
will say for applications though the
plastic will need to keep the water out
for the lifetime of the product and
right now we don't have inexpensive
flexible packages that provide a
suitable barrier so it's going to be
important for there to be breakthroughs
on that but if the product didn't need
to have a long lifetime then it would
certainly be possible right now to to do
flexible perovskite solar cells another
question would it be possible to go to
100% tin for the purpose of getting the
lead out and people are working hard on
that and I'm not sure what the latest
efficiency is there I'm sure people have
gotten 8% and I think it's in that maybe
eight eight to ten perhaps as high as
12% with all tin so it's not quite yet
as good as LED however there have been
reports that tin is actually more toxic
than lead
the toxicity of lead is very well-known
but it actually as far as toxic things
go that is not that bad and there are a
lot of things that are worse that just
somehow haven't picked up the reputation
so I'm not sure switching to ten for the
purpose of reducing toxicity is going to
be helpful
people are also switching to business
which unfortunately doesn't have the
right chart or is it it's not a plus two
it's a plus three and then you have to
balance that with a plus one so if you
use silver in business for example Hema
Karuna dasa at Stanford does that but
it's not yet anywhere near as good as
these lead compounds so suffice it to
say there there are research groups
trying to find lead-free compounds
looking at some of the other questions
people are asking yeah what would the
cost of these panels be that's a great
question so we have worked with Mike
Woodhouse at the National Renewable
Energy Lab who leads a team that does
cost modeling and they call companies
and they find out what all the materials
are going to cost and they find out how
much it would cost to use the tools to
do all of the processing steps and
people in industry seem to agree that
that the results from that group are
pretty accurate and so they project that
if you just did single Junction parofsky
panels they'd be just a little bit
cheaper than cadmium telluride because
you can deposit the Prostate more easily
but not dramatically cheaper and that's
because so much of the cost is in things
like the packaging and the junction box
where the wires come out so that's why
like when people tell you they're going
to drop the costs by an order of
magnitude using solution processing
usually have not accounted for the
packaging in the tandems the way we like
to think of it is let's say you have a
silicon panel and you want to upgrade to
attend them we we project that down the
road the silicon panel would be about
$80 per meter squared we think the
upgrade cost is going to be about $24
per meter squared when you convert it to
a dollar per watt we think that it'll be
about the same so it'll cost more but
it'll also be more efficient where you
really win is that with these panels
that have over 25 percent efficiency you
won't need to install as many of them to
get a given amount of power and the big
savings will be over on the on the
installation side of things and that's
why it's compelling to to do this okay
let me look at some of these other ones
someone's asking what about the
performance in direct versus diffuse
light so these will work fine and
diffuse light unlike gallium arsenide
cells those are tiny and they are used
with concentrators and those are either
lenses or reflectors that focus the
light onto the cell and they only work
with the direct light the diffused light
doesn't properly get through the optical
system but we won't be using
concentration and so our ours will work
fine
there there's a fine point here with the
tandems clouds change the spectrum and
so if you have designed your tandem to
work well under the so called am 1.5
conditions which is a bright day with no
clouds the tandem might not work
properly with clouds and nor will it
work well at sunrise or sunset when the
spec
has changed it it will still work and my
group and several others are trying to
calculate the loss over a typical year
and it appears that it could be around
10 to 15 percent it's why I prefer the
mechanically stack tandem because we can
use a little circuit in between the
profs kite and silicon solar cells to
maintain the current matching condition
and so we wouldn't have to pay that
penalty there someone says is there any
work in progress to you to utilize
graphene as a substrate
well graphene as you know is also a
pretty good transparent conductor and
there are some academic groups trying to
use it as an electrode and it would also
I think dramatically improve the
stability of the solar cell hardly
anything can go through graphene I hope
there are advances in depositing large
sheets of graphene I haven't followed
the latest on that but I'm not aware of
any real practical way to put down large
sheets of it I think you could have lots
of small flakes and that's kind of like
those carbon pastes that that I briefly
alluded to that have been used and they
did result in very stable devices
someone's asking about printing and I
think this is just being touched on and
at this time I don't think it's clear
whether it should be a slot dye coated
or blade coated or grow viewer coated or
perhaps even inkjet printed with an
array of nozzles I think what is for
sure is that it should not be spin
coated an industry scale because spin
coating it doesn't work well for very
large area and it also wastes so much of
the solution so we definitely want a
printing technique where almost all of
the ink does actually end up in the
solar cell and only a few labs are are
working on the scale up right now to go
to larger area there there definitely
needs to be a lot more work in that area
there's a question do I think mechanical
versus monolithic will be the better
design for tandems so I believe in
mechanical and I have a few reasons for
that one of them is I was over saying
how if the spectrum changes you know
during the course of the day or through
the seasons and the current match is
lost you could use circuitry to fix it
another one is it's just a practical
business concern if someone were to make
the the high band gap top cells they
could partner with any company that
makes either silicon or cigs and and
those companies would not have to modify
their product they wouldn't have to
change the texturing but they use at the
top of their cell they wouldn't have to
change their electrode pattern whereas
if you go monolithic you've got to keep
at the top of your silicon smooth and
and that that's not as easy as it as it
may sound now some believe in monolithic
when you do that you you you get rid of
one of the transparent conductors that
you need and the mechanically stacked
tandems and each one of those conductors
costs you about 10% of the photons and
so that I'm sure eventually the world
record efficiency will come from a
monolithic design but what's best to get
a world record in an academic lab and
what's most practical for business I
think are two different
things so not surprisingly people have
asked for the expected time to market
that's always the toughest question for
a professor to answer I've certainly
never seen anything progressed as
rapidly as this has and a lot of times
the community poses a problem and it
gets solved in just a matter of 3 to 12
months so things are moving forward very
very rapidly however I'm anticipating
very serious financing problems it's all
of the startups are having tremendous
difficulty raising capital a lot of
investors lost money you know total of
billions of dollars were lost between
2005 and 2015 and so there's a
reluctance right now to invest and I
guess if I look forward here either
either some people are gonna step up
soon and invest or the numbers are just
going to get more and more compelling
the efficiencies are going to keep
rising the industry-standard
stability tests I believe will be passed
we may see academics and National Labs
start the scale up and demonstrate that
there are no issues and then hopefully
investors will be willing to put in the
tens of millions that will be needed for
a pilot line and then I think things
could proceed very quickly I think one
thing some people learned from the
failures of the last decade is that you
don't want to you don't want to have 8
to 10 innovations at the same time you
don't want to completely redesign the
panel you don't want to get into a
situation where you need to build custom
tools because you're doing something
that's never been done before and these
designs that I talked about today they
can all be implemented with
off-the-shelf tools that you can get
from companies like Applied Materials
and and you can even like in Silicon
Valley you know the tools are around and
you could be using used tools in a pilot
line situation and so in a best-case
scenario I think products could be ready
in a few years but financing problems
might might extend that okay well thank
you for answering those questions and
thank you for those of you who sent them
in we had a fantastic number I think we
will learn a lot more today I want to
thank you for attending the webinar and
hope that you'll be able to join us
again in the future for other faculty
talks so enjoy the rest of your day